Takata in F by Charles Marie Vidor
they hear an endless variety of colors
they feel through the floor the rumble
of the deepest base pipes
when they hear that they'll say that is
Woolsey Hall at Yale
my name is Thomas Murray and I've been
very fortunate over 38 years to teach
graduate organ performance Majors here
on this magnificent order the largest
pipes in the organ are 32 feet high from
the mouth to the top the four keyboards
of this organ each control a section of
it and the sections consist of pipes
organized by what we call stops there
are a lot of people in the world who
don't understand the origin of the
expression pulling out all the stops
we at Yale have sought to maintain this
organ in its original form without doing
things that would change its style it's
what we would call an orchestral style
instrument I feel intense Delight in
being able to orchestrate things to
choose the colors that I feel are just
right for any given section of Any Given
piece
another thing which I feel is the sense
of being in touch with history this
organ
was built in stages and the final stage
was 1929 so we are hearing the same
sounds that the crowd heard when this
was dedicated for the third time
the world needs to know how special it
is and Yale is very fortunate to have it
[Music]